it's just before Christmas and the
people in the countryside near Moscow
are up early at least most of the men
are there off on a quest to back the
perfect catch the famous Christmas fish
thank you all for coming we'll be
fishing over there in the pond let's go
competitive fishing is a popular
Christmas tradition here 40 anglers have
turned up today both young and old some
are old hands others beginners all that
matters is the trout in Soviet times
there was a fish processing factory here
but it closed down long ago but the fish
are still here much to the delight of
the villagers more the public would push
the great thing is that you can go
anywhere on the pond without a boat you
can go looking for the fish and for a
bit of happiness yes dude where you not
sure where's your leadership what
quarter Bureau my daughter is doing
better than me I've only just caught my
first one solemn we salt the fish or
cook it in the oven with vegetables
there's a lot more you can do this war
between emotions deal with
three and a half hours on the ice
waiting for a bite no one wants to give
up despite the freezing temperatures
it's minus 16 degrees because the cold
doesn't bother these fishermen quite
opposite effect they are happy that the
real winter has finally arrived to now
in Russia at Christmas time for 70 years
under communist rule Christmas was
banned and people had to celebrate in
secret going fishing was not a problem
of course but going to church was since
the collapse of the Soviet Union in 1991
the Orthodox Church has seen a huge
resurgence and now Christmas is once
again one of the most important
festivals in the Christian calendar much
of the celebrating takes place outside
in the community so how much does this
one way let's see look at that two point
six eight kilos Gennady Vladimirovich
takes first place with seven point nine
kilos in total congratulations there's
Russian champagne for the winner and
plenty of Christmas cheer for all the
anglers